Speaker 1: So to recap, the Macron variant
is now wreaking havoc throughout the U.S.
and the rest of the world, and we're now seeing
at least 100000 new cases of COVID every single
day here in the U.S., with estimates showing
that it could get a lot worse.
But there are some people suggesting that
there's no reason to worry because yes, while
Macron is quite contagious and we may see
a lot of infections, it's not going to be
very deadly.
We're not going to see a big spike in the
death numbers.
And the evidence that people base that off
of is the fact that we have this data out
of South Africa where the variant is believed
to have originated, and it just wasn't all
that deadly there.
Well, there's this great piece now in NPR
highlighting that what we saw in South Africa
may not exactly match up with what we're going
to see here in the U.S.
We certainly hope that it does.
We certainly hope that there's not this big
spike in the death numbers, but we just we
don't know for sure we can't exactly bank
on that.
A study out of South Africa with 200000 COVID
positive participants, about a quarter of
whom had serious underlying health conditions,
was underway between September and November
of this year.
So that's the tail end of the delta wave,
along with the beginning of the al-Muqrin
wave.
Researchers found that as time went on and
al-Muqrin became dominant, there was a 30
percent drop in hospitalizations from this
pool of people with the COVID cases.
The rate of hospitalization for all Macron
was quite low as only 58 per 1000, which is
the lowest of the four COVID waves that the
country has experienced since this all started
two years ago.
Hard to believe it's been that long.
Not only that, instances of patients needing
oxygen or ventilation dropped and ICU stays
went down to only 13 percent from where it
was at, at 30 percent.
Also, people recovered a lot quicker than
in the previous waves.
So there you go, right?
We're going to be just fine here.
Well, maybe let's let's hold our horses here
because the key variable is that the data
did not take into account previous exposure
to the virus.
And many of these cases were reinfections,
with South Africa believed to have a much
higher level of immunity than we have here
in the United States.
Now the vaccination rates in South Africa,
they're quite a bit lower.
Only about one in four South Africans had
been vaccinated by the time that al-Muqrin
hit.
But the vast majority of residents in South
Africa had so-called natural immunity, having
had a previous version of coronavirus.
So between previous infections and the amount
of people who are vaccinated in South Africa,
there were just few people statistically left
who hadn't been exposed to either the virus
or the vaccine.
Nearly everyone in this COVID pool that they
looked at had some version of immunity.
And we know that when you get COVID for a
second time or when you get it after having
been vaccinated, symptoms aren't nearly as
bad.
The death counts aren't nearly as bad, and
your recovery time is generally a lot quicker.
So key to understanding this may be to figure
out the number of people in the U.S. with
no previous exposure to COVID or the vaccine,
and we'll have to see.
We'll have to wait and see how this is going
to affect them.
As of now, about 62 percent of Americans have
been vaccinated, fully vaccinated with the
two doses, and an estimated 20 percent of
Americans have been infected with COVID since
the start of the pandemic.
It's hard to believe it's only 20 percent.
You'd think it'd be a lot higher than that
number.
Now, obviously, there's going to be some crossover
between these two groups of people because
some people got vaccinated and then later
got a breakthrough case of COVID.
There's also people who got COVID early on
and then later got vaccinated.
So you can't just like, add up the two numbers
and come up with your overall immunity number.
But when you actually crunched the numbers,
when you do it appropriately, it turns out
that 20 percent of Americans, that's 66 million
people have no immunity at all.
And that leaves plenty of people who could
potentially get a serious case, depending
really on how severe all Macron is.
And again, we just don't know yet, so we can
be optimistic about the variant.
But we have to be cautiously optimistic, and
the best way to do that is to obviously observe
the normal protocols.
Wear the mask, socially distance, get vaccinated.
If you're eligible, get the booster shot,
if you can.
I just got my booster shot a couple of days
ago wasn't feeling so great yesterday, but
you know, I got over the side effects in about
a day or so.
Do all the right things.
Make sure that we don't just throw caution
to the wind here and make sure that we observe
the right protocols.
And hopefully Omicron doesn't turn out to
be so bad, but we just don't know for sure
yet.
We're going to go to a break.
We'll be back with much, much more on the
David Pakman show right after this.